this is Startalk all right this is from
Amanda Milligan mm-hmm she says in every
document where she from she from Earth
she is from Earth okay
she's just from Earth in every
documentary I have seen lately
extraterrestrial life is animal how do
you think plant life would evolve
outside of our own world or could there
be life that exists that could not be
classified as either plant nor animal
it's still life there's a famous science
fiction story and forgive me for I
forgot who wrote it cuz that I don't
come in here with notes in anticipate
don't know these questions so how could
I write so so there's a science fiction
story where the aliens came upon earth
mm-hmm and saw that we there's like
muscle tissue and right and they go back
to their home planet and says they're
made of meat because the aliens they're
made of some spirit energy right right
and we're made of meat right and another
thing that we take for granted but I can
imagine an alien life-form that would
just freak out mm-hmm other than salt
other than salt animals have to kill to
consume food other than the consumption
of salt everything else you eat was once
alive right well that's our sorry sorry
unless you live off of milk and honey
all right
those themselves animal that's an animal
by-product you have to kill something
and even the vegetarians taste it was
live slaughtering carries that's right
all right yeah and slicing them dicing
them up and shredding them yes
so the fact that we have to kill other
life-forms on our own planet for our own
sustenance could easily be seen as one
of the most barbaric things to another
civilization where they all absorb
energy from their host star right yes
there you have because they're absorbing
and not consuming well there and and and
they're not ingesting they're unlimited
source of energy from their Sun just
like planets by plants on earth right
they don't have to eat anything there's
some to do of course but most nearly all
other planets don't the Venus flytrap
is carnivorous and what's the other one
that eats flies that smells like picture
plan there's one it that you're telling
about the one that smells like rotten
Marion yeah yeah rotting flesh yeah so
that one okay so they're carnivorous but
all the rest it's your plan are doing
just fine with sunlight yeah and that's
that's an awesome way to live I think if
I were to evolve the human into us in
another forum I'd involve us with solar
panels on our skin nice eye skin would
be one big solar yeah and that way
getting sunburned you just recharge your
your energetics yes I believe they call
that African I'm just sayin
last I heard this that's why they're
black yep I say okay I just said that's
why they're black that's so crazy this
is Startalk